بعيدا عن جفاف الصيف الذي عانت منه فرنسا
العام الماضي ياتي شتاؤها هذا العام
مصحوبا بانخفاض كبير في هطول الامطار هنا
على ضفاف نهر السن يبدو المشهد واضحا
فمنسوب النهر في هذه الفتره من السنه لا
يشبه ما سبقها في ظاهره غير معتاده في
البلد الذي لطالما عرف بوفره مياهه شبحوا
التصحر يطل من جديدا على الاراضي الفرنسيه
لكن هذه المره في فصل الشتاء فمنذ اكثر من
شهر لم تهطل الامطار الا نادرا هذه
الظاهره قد تشكل تهديدا مباشرا للمحاصيل
الزراعيه وقد تتسبب ايضا بحرائق في
الغابات خبراء البيئه قلقون ويدعون للحذر
في فصل الربيع اذا دمنا في هذا المنح يعني
قله امطار وشحف الامطار
ان هذا الامر سوف يؤدي الى عدم تعبئه
المياه الجوفيه في فرنسا
والى مشاكل نفاد في المياه شرح في المياه
على مستوى
مختلف الاراضي لمكافحه خطر التصحر قررت
بلديات في مقاطعه فار بجنوب فرنسا عدم
اصدار تصاريح للبناء فيما طالبت الحكومه
المواطنين بتوفير المياه واعتزمت اللجوء
الى اعاده استخدام المياه المعالجه
في المدن الكبرى لا نشعر بانعكاسات شح
الامطار كالقرى لكن مستقبلا هذا الامر
مقلق تكرير المياه سيستهلك ايضا طاقه
كبيره وهذا لن يحل المشكله بل سيؤخرها فقط
اكثر المشاهد قساوه لهذا الجفاف هي صور
اخذت حديثا لنهر الوار اطول انهار فرنسا
الذي تكون مياهه عاده في ذروتها في هذه
الفتره من السنه نتيجه ذوبان الثلوج لكن
ينابيع هذا النهر جفت بشكل كبير في سابقه
من نوعها في البلاد زرعت العربيه باريس